So here's a pseudo co-description of an algorithm that follows what we did as
humans. Now let's think about this a little more carefully. So the questions is;
Should we go ahead and implement this algorithm? Are we close enough to start
writing the actual python code? There are four choices. First is that yes, we
should go ahead and implement this, and we'll end up with the correct solution.
The second is that; We should start implementing this. It doesn't address all
cases, but this is a good start and we'll figure out the details as we go. The
third choice is no, that we should figure out how to address all the cases first
and make sure that we have correct pseudo code before we try writing any actual
python code. And finally no, we should give up on this direction and try to find
a simpler way to solve this problem.